did I see something in the news recently
some like about uh just some
love for Jason newstead like everything
like they think so yeah they've really I
think it's one of the things they've
been opening up about because in
retrospect and maybe it's because they
started to talk about it now it's like
the way that how they handled it yeah
and the more they're like really
exploring how they handle him they
really [__] they hurt him man I mean
yeah for people who don't know
okay he was the one who replaced
Clifford yeah Metallica after Cliff died
I see Chris died in 1986. yeah on tour
with Ozzy yeah they were they were on a
bus the bus had a slippery Road and
Scandinavia and it flipped over oh he's
the only one that died the only one that
died and they had they had drawn straws
to about like which bunk they were gonna
sleep in and I forget if uh Cliff got
the longest star he Cho he got first
choice and according to the story
he wanted Kirk's bunk so he switched
bunks with Kirk so at when the when the
bus accident happened he was in that
bunk when it could have been Kirk who
who died so it's like it's a I mean the
the myth the Mythos over surrounding
that accident is so huge you can
actually drive to that spot and there's
a memorial where where Cliff died like
it's that it's that powerful
um and it's three hours out of the way
it's crazy man I mean it's one of those
drives where today a band at that level
would probably fly because of the the
terrain and how crazy it gets up there
um so they replaced the replacement
Jason who was the bass player for a band
called Jetson Jetson and he's a massive
Metallica fan
um they had a lot of people actually try
out for the spawn including
um
a guy from Primus let's play pool
actually try it out and they were like
this is interesting but this isn't us
yeah it's crazy right right
um could you imagine Les Claypool with
Metallica like put the [__] [__]
you're just like I think that that it
just uh from a type A personality type
thing that that wouldn't have worked it
would have been a totally different band
too many chiefs exactly
um so that's when they people say like
Metallica turned down less Claypool
that's the reason why because I've
always heard that I'm like why would
they turn it down well they turned him
down because honestly at the time it
didn't make sense you know and honestly
this was before Primus was even a
household name you know everybody people
need to remember the first album that
Jason did was actually the garage Days
album which was the cover album garage
days
re-revisited I still up until a couple
years ago had my original copy I had the
598 ep the cassette because they had the
590 ADP and then they had the uh the 798
vinyl because every it was always
affordable but it was always a different
price for the different format and
whatnot how many tracks can you remember
from Garage Days re-revisited green hell
last correct oh yeah uh Green Hill
Alaska rest there was a the weight yeah
uh there was helpless yeah
um crash course from brain surgery yeah
and there was uh the small hours that's
the whole out and then with uh [__]
oh dude that's one of my favorite albums
of all time it's epic and they built
they recorded it in this garage that
they that they built basically to kind
of do just let's just do something and
Vibe and see what happens so this was
before and justice for all so they
record that they go in it's super
[__] punk rock it's super like yeah
it's dirty and it's a great [__]
album man and that led to going into
doing Injustice for all which a lot of
people think was a reaction to
the fact that they were subliminally
dealing with the death because there's
no base on that album at all really yeah
they're they're you can go on YouTube
and find versions where people have
added bass and they call it and justice
for Jason because they buried him in the
mix I mean it's such a two two-track mix
that you're listening to it going am I
meant what the [__] going on here
because I remember I stood in line
waiting for that album to come out and I
bought it and I listened to it and the
first time I listened to it I was like
this is [__] crushes it's killer and
then I started going well it doesn't
sound as thick as their other stuff you
know but you didn't mind because it was
riffy as [__] you know thick is the base
exactly and they think people talk about
whether or not that was them
subliminally reacting to the fact that
Cliff was dead and purportedly the way
they've they treated Jason over the
years was really really bad and even
James has admitted yeah because I mean
it's it's tough you know I mean you just
lost somebody you were in the trenches
with they were all young they didn't
know how to process grief nobody helped
them process it so what they did was
they took it out on the new guy or got
really [__] up yeah yeah yeah
I mean it was crazy what if it's really
just something special when
people step up and acknowledge that's
really big and it's it's something that
and this is how sad it is when it
happens it it catches You by surprise
because not a lot of people do it right
which you wish it was the opposite you
know it's like you wish that it would
just be something that you just take for
granted it's like of course oh [__] of
course man my bad I I was totally in the
wrong if more people right would own
everything they do not just the good
[__] the bad man you would just I think
there would be more of an embracing of
humanity as a whole big time yeah an
example of that which I I think is just
so epic
Bill Clinton after his presidency right
stepped up to acknowledge his failure to
intervene on what happened in Rwanda
right right and that was really nice and
he's 100 correct to be you know like he
really it was in his hand right and he
you know
it was totally a genocide right oh 100
yeah yeah why should on him just because
he's a bass player I mean you wouldn't
do that if you brought on a new singer
well
it's largely because they didn't like I
said they didn't know how to deal with
grief and even though J and I think one
of the things is because Jason was such
a nice guy
that he was such a like it was a little
bit like karabi coming into the crew
where he was like dude I can't believe
I'm in Metallica and they're like buddy
we're not looking for a fan right we're
looking for a basis we're looking for
somebody who's gonna you know help us
take it because one of the reasons why
Robert works is because Robert was
Robert for years you know he's a fan but
he also knows how to hold his own
whereas Jason came in and was just you
know like you know you [__] grew up
listening to Metallica yeah like they
had done shows together on festivals and
whatnot he was a [__] fan
so when you're already dealing with the
negativity of grief
and you also compound it with alcohol
your your perspective on some [__] like
that can be skewed and a harsh
how do I say this nicely a harsh
personality will dissect that and then
destroy you for it someone that positive
and that stoked about life yeah coming
into that situation with three people
who are really [__] hurting you add
alcohol and
you know repression
and they're going to they're going to go
you know what you're done I'm going to
shred you I'm going to [__] and that's
that's sad it's human nature though I
think there's another level too of just
um like the the type A like the the
rights the Chiefs thing right just
there's a level of connection yeah yeah
and Lars and James are kind of notorious
for that oh do you like shopping on
Amazon I do and good news is
for your butt wall are
of on Amazon and if you want a real
bundle of a deal you can get Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole plus Stephen's
butthole destroyer and Stevo's butt
wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right now yeah
yeah dude